one of the men who was in better call
saul um and so terrific in this and i'm
a big fan of his and thrilled that he's
calling in now in support of his new
movie playing god which is available now
in theaters vod and all digital
platforms michael mckeon here on the
rich island show how are you sir
i'm good rich
how's everything there uh we're we're
good we're healthy we're knocking on
wood getting ready for an nfl season
talking pop cultural all good times okay
just look i can't talk nfl with you it's
okay uh you know i i will his name his
name is still playing well here's the
kind on
i think joe is selling gold on certain
parts of the cave
out of the trees
no come on that's a bad joke uh i've no
i i was i was never it's funny i was
never a football fan always baseball
fans okay but my dad my dad was one of
those guys in the late 60s live or die
with the jets
well
you you saved yourself a lifetime
but so so are you i saw you met yankee
which baseball team were you were you
are your friend oh sir i was
i was uh i grew up in new york yes and
uh when i was an infant my father told
me that the dodgers were the team to
root for because uh aside from jackie
robinson i was also the rookie of the
year in 1946
[Music]
and uh so i was always a dodger fan uh
when they moved i kind of powered on
baseball i tried to root for the mats
they i thought they were
really fun to watch and everything but
then when they got good it was sort of
right around the time that i moved to la
and i became a dodger fan again so
uh anyway well no it's a look man i mean
dodger stadium i i it's funny because
i'm from staten island new york you're
from manhattan right michael correct
yeah all right well uh yeah but i grew
up on long island okay so you're you're
a new yorker so you know that we've
always grew up viewing los angeles
sports fans is a little soft for showing
up late to games and leaving early
because because of the traffic but they
do but
ever since i've moved here to los
angeles i am one of those people i am
i am unabashedly one of those people you
know i've never i've never left the game
early but uh
uh i i like to come early too and get my
hot dog dealings done
and all that you know it's it is a great
place to see a ball game but so is
fenway so is wrigley uh you know i think
thank god for ballparks and you know we
didn't get there this year or last year
last ball game i saw i think no we saw
one dodgy game before that i went to an
oakland game for the first time you know
it was uh my wife was doing a show up
there and it was really fun in oakland
up there at the the ancient stadium up
there oh my god yeah which was which was
great it's kind of like a prison
no i mean no i know what you mean it
doesn't look anything it's it's one of
those old dual purpose
parks you know where
where you know
but there's incredible history there
from the oakland raiders to the old a's
with reggie jackson and catfish hunter
and sure you know him well back in the
day yeah you know and they're still
great fans i mean oakland has amazing
fans
in general so i've no i have come to
know no but namath is one of my favorite
people on on planet earth i mean never
met him oh my gosh
i am in my in my job with the nfl
network michael uh i've been fortunate
to have come across him and everybody
knows what what it means to me and one
time he one time he reached out he gave
me a hug and like literally i started
crying
like
you know what i mean
it's just i i got hugged by peter falk
once
i i had met him a couple of times i had
dinner with him once way but many years
before yes and and then i was in this
movie and he came to see it because his
pal was in it yes and and he gave me
this big hug and it was just there you
go okay i'm good i'm good now well i
mean i i i think i think nate peter falk
is sort of the nameth of uh of
television detectives in a way you know
you know what's great about him i was
thinking about him because i you know
people want to start careers they want
to be in movies and all that stuff and
they wonder if they're not pretty enough
or if they don't you know look at the
right way or enough like brittany or
enough like brad pitt or whatever
you know imagine you're you know in the
early 50s you're an efficiency expert at
a factory
and you have a glass eye and a speech
impediment and you're about five sevens
or five eight
should you become a movie star well if
you're peter falk absolutely
you know what i'm saying it's like it's
like be who you really are and there's
nowhere else they can buy it well i i
read somewhere michael mckeon once that
and that by the way this is what i love
about this show and also getting to meet
you is i i didn't think i'd wake up
today talking about peter falk with
michael mckeon but this is what this is
life i i heard once that the reason why
in colombo that he always looked down
was hunched because that's the way he
could see where his mark was to hit on
television
that's what i heard
i don't know if possible but you know
what
almost every close-up you see
of spencer tracy begins with him looking
at the floor or it was until it was cut
out he always wanted to be on his mark
so they wouldn't have to shoot it again
it's just standard practice and
sometimes if you work it into a master
shot see in
in tv they would stay on the master shot
as much as possible you know they wanted
to get finished by lunch so there's a
there's a very there's a simplicity to
it i'm sure that's exactly what he was
doing and yet who didn't believe that he
was actually thinking about it this case
you know
searching for clues michael mckeon here
on the rich eisen show before i i dive
deep into your your tv and filmography
let's talk about playing god which is
available now in theaters yeah vod and
all digital platforms why why uh why
this film and what what'd you like about
it that people should go see michael
well i just got this call out of the
blue and they sent me the script and i
you know i saw
yeah i kind of get what this is this
this could be really fun it's really
interesting and then they told me that
alan tunic was involved and i was a fan
of his
firefly series and uh you know just he's
one of those guys who's always good
and scs could be good go to atlanta i
mean to sorry to houston
for three weeks three weeks okay it's
gonna be warm we know that
and uh you say i'm gonna be sitting on a
rooftop in houston with a three-piece
black suit okay well we'll try that
so
it just it looked like an interesting
thing an interesting story
um i didn't know uh hannah uh
and or luca didn't know them previous to
this
uh although it turned out later i had
seen hannah in something uh they're
really really good and like
damn easy on the eye both of them
and uh they're this kind of brother
sister
on team you know who goes after a big a
big prize
which turns out to be a lot more
complicated especially when you get into
the the afterlife
and the deities walking around in
three-piece suit it's like you
on rooftop
uh yes uh i should point out a phony
baloney deity and uh you know but
but it's all about this guy's it's all
about the character that alan plays it's
all about his
his journey you know and he's kind of
the ticking heart at the middle of this
well playing i think it's a nice spell
playing god is available now in theaters
vod and all digital platforms and uh
starring michael mckeon who's here on
the rich eisen show um usually i can go
deep dive into somebody's tv and
filmography but here on the show we play
a game called celebrity true or false
where there are some items that have
been written about you and then the
wikipedia um bullet points that we're
wondering are true or false and we'd
love for you to refute or or confirm for
us if that's okay yeah there's there are
some famous uh mistakes floating around
okay so let's let's correct the record
i've been told let's correct the record
here we go we have actual production
value with it go ahead and hit it
everybody go ahead
[Music]
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth there you go that's our
production value michael mckeon that's
our production value a celebrity true or
false what is what is the actual value
of that that production makes me enjoy
it like brings a smile to my face to be
very honest no i meant money i'm talking
money um i i think it's it pays for it
it pays for itself michael you know what
i mean brilliant that sort of thing i
appreciate that all right first item of
forbids you and david lander were
originally hired as riders on laverne
and shirley and wrote yourself into the
show as lenny and squiggy two characters
you created while in college true or
false
that's true that is uh i would have to
add one name uh harry shearer
who was with david and myself a member
of a group called the credibility gap
which was a satirical group here
la radio and uh we we've made some
albums went out on the road in clubs and
concerts etc
um and we were known as the credibility
gap at this point
and penny
marshall and rob reiner were big fans of
these characters that we would do
just kind of but we we cut they were in
the act kind of toward the end in the
credibility gap back toward the end but
mainly we just did them because these
two idiots entertained our friends who
are also idiots
and so we uh but penny and rock any you
know kenny and cindy sold this show gary
marshall who create co-created the show
with lower gans and mark rodman
um they they got they got to go on this
show that they had done not a pilot but
what you call a presentation film for
showing some of their stuff from their
two appearances on happy days girls
and so bingo we got a sale and he said
you guys should come to this party we're
having and maybe you can do those guys
you know that uh okay okay so david and
i went to this party at penny's house
penny and rob's house when they were
married
and uh uh lowell gans was there mark
rothman some other producers for show
and we you know at one point rob said to
us do the guys do the guys
and david david and i went into a piece
that we had never done before never even
thought before and we we never did after
that
uh where the guys discussed going to
butler school
to become valet
and it was pretty funny as i recall
because everybody was laughing but i
couldn't tell you a thing about it right
yeah and then you wrote yourself and
then you wrote yourself into the show
and then off you go well penny penny
always had in mind you know an eye
toward maybe we can write these guys in
yeah you know because they're they're
funny kind of 50s characters
so uh we you know
it was
it was not something we just volunteered
it was like you know gary thought the
characters were funny everybody thought
characters are funny we wrote him in all
right and then we wrote him into the
first episode and everyone after that
and then so the next item uh here on
celebrity true or false with you michael
mckeon is that those characters were so
popular you released a 1979 album called
lenny in the squig tones which featured
a young guitarist credited as nigel
toughnell
christopher guest
and that was the name that he used
obviously in spinal tap is that true
well that was his that was his english
rocker name he uh you know he had he had
done a version of that kind of character
since
i mean since i've known him which was
the late 60s is when
chris and i met at at nyu
and started writing songs together and
stuff and just being silly so why and
so let me let us get a question about
christopher guest who's
his movies are spectacular and you in
them as well were you were you in
waiting for goffman or you were not in
waiting for governor no i wouldn't know
i it was uh i
the original plan was for uh chris and i
to work on this way the government idea
was
was something that he wanted to do it
was inspired by a
a documentary is seen about a small
city with an opera house and a guy who
was just dying to get on stage and be a
spear carrier at the opera that was the
initial thing
and then it kind of expanded and his
notion was to make it a a small town
doing their you know
some kind of celebration and this
historical play that this guy's putting
on you know built around this character
that chris loved to do this you know
flamboyant
uh very self-involved
you know guy who's just dying to get to
broadway
uh which was such a such an amazing such
a big character
so originally i was going to work on it
and then uh i was doing snl and then i
was doing the brady bunch movie and that
was the chunk of time that he was he's
kind of set apart
and so instead he he got in touch with
eugene which was an awfully good idea
and he didn't know eugene he was just a
fan of his work on sctp
etc and uh
so
you know they just they got together and
and you know gene showed up at his at
chris's cabin up in the woods and they
uh they worked on this this idea and
they hatched it into a brilliant movie
so so you worked out that's how he met
eugene levy to get in all of this so uh
who's the one on all of these films
because much of it was i imagine
ad-libbed who was the one that was the
one that would crack everybody up the
most or easiest to crack up
the most oh michael
the most difficult to work with well
first of all all of the dialogue all the
dialogue and chris's stuff is is
revised as it was in this is final path
the film that we that rob reiner directs
that we you know that that was kind of
the model for that this
this kind of work
and uh
yeah a lot of times i have to say fred
willard
um
jennifer coolidge
uh higgins
higgins was was hard to it was so
brilliantly funny but he was only hard
to work with because he was so
smart as fast
it wasn't like looking out of danger
i was in danger of going
excuse me can i say that on the radio
maybe not well it's okay you were
breaking up on your phone that's perfect
time so so which so which one was the
easiest to to crack up who was the one
that was simple that you would just
break
uh
i broke i broke chris a couple of times
that's it edifying fine word for it
yeah and uh
and a refugee base when he was in the
for consideration
and i had one little piece with him and
i had a feeling about him that he was
ready to fall on the floor at all times
i love that he didn't
yeah yeah no but he just he
loved being on the show so much
you know
we loved him so much and it was really
fun all right i've got two i've got two
more for you michael mckeon uh here you
go first one uh you just mentioned rob
reiner is it true or false that he was
gonna originally be in a spinal tap band
member but became the director because
he didn't look good in spandex true or
false no
that's false that's false
of course
[Applause]
although now i'm thinking about rob ryan
and spandex thanks very much my
apologies then okay um then
see that's why we ask you this to make
that make sure it's these things we read
are true or false
last one for you you were asked to join
the original cast of breaking bad
but because of conflicting stage
commitments you could not do it is that
true or false
all i can say is that there was a a a
casting a thing that vince directed
called me directly about
and he said there's a part we'd like you
to do on this and i couldn't because i
was on my way to new york to do a play
so that's that's all that uh you know
i'm i'm not going to talk about what
particularly
and then it becomes you know it becomes
fan stuff and it's like you know it's
better you guys to just kind of guess
you know which one would it be would it
be no
you won't even you won't even twitch in
the direction if i guess which one it
would be
uh michael it was not salamanca that's
all of it that's not solomon
okay that leaves
oh boy his phone's breaking up well
michael look i i appreciate you taking
the time here uh on the rich eisen show
i could i could go on and on and on with
you but i appreciate the time congrats
on playing god available now in theaters
vod and other digital platforms will and
all digital platforms we'll we'll
hopefully pick this up another time
thank you right back at you at michael
at mj mckeon
m-c-k-e-a-n
right here on the rich eisen show
now i'm just gonna thank the rest of the
show who he could have been on irmantrap
that's a possibility i think that's on
the list
who else would it be
who else could possibly be pinkman
definitely not
obviously the motherlode of all of the
we'd like to try if he was walter white
that's why you know
i mean could he have been hank
that'd have been a good one
hank
the brother-in-law who is on to
everything
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here